[Music]
in game of sensors news submitted by
boats and hoes both the HOS Game of
Thrones viewers in China are begging for
explicit scenes to not be censored in
the final season they're begging for it
to not be censored and it's it's all the
violence all of the sex violence - yeah
right yeah violence sex like blood
everything like red wedding was like
completely like chopped up so people are
basically saying that like they've been
watching the show through the streaming
service but it's completely censored and
even though in some episodes only 90
seconds or five minutes are missing
things feel like disjointed yeah they'll
try to leave things in but like glue of
Game of Thrones
yeah I feel there was a lot there wasn't
a lot of booty like I only watched the
first season but I saw Emilia Clarke
I saw dick a lot of dick this dick on
game agree on the Greyjoy great choice
always - you want to be in hard to know
if it's hard it's a porno isn't it no
I'm just saying like what does that do
for the lady I feel like at least for a
guy though like a father song set I'd be
like ask the producer like hey man can I
just get like a little hard it would be
like the girls like [ __ ] soaking wet
they don't show that either that will be
awesome but he also don't show vagina
yeah you shut the frontage ina the show
but vagina
yeah but the Frog vagina looks no
different than the armpit closed good
point that's true so it's nothing
special I feel like in the first half
let's gonna show you a vagina right now
little did oh you did okay do it does oh
that's true I think I think like the
first season or so I watched Emilia
Clarke get like slammed on a rock yeah
yeah yeah vizor
Oh baby Dani Darth right dick hey hey
hey but that was that was rape and I
don't condone that [ __ ] from Jason Momoa
I don't think when I was married to like
I think she's the lady from like The
Cosby Show she's like half black and I
was like oh I know they give her the
scene from um oh my god what's the name
what's the movie the recent movie where
the girl falls in love with the sea
creature water like where she walks over
to him she's naked but I'm I saw that in
China they made they like put a dress on
her
in Fiji I know they're really pretty
strict with that should have formed out
there I actually worked a lot last year
to you ladies no thrusting too much too
much dick movements to see it and even
small things like Oh at like 30 minutes
12 seconds this frame the guy will have
his hand on his crotch while he was
grooving take that out yeah
really beginning or even stuff like okay
the the girl came out from between his
leg just as a dance move cut that out
it's [ __ ] crazy just wearing a suit
like like a wardrobe gave you like a
certain outfit and like your dick was
just too big like would they make them
like tape it down or just like cut all
those scenes out they'll probably cut us
you know Jesus yeah it's pretty
controlling I don't think they'll have
that problem is China
and I can say that because I'm Asian
[ __ ] work growers not showers
not really is huge guys
super he's really big hey hey hey it's
not it's not when it's flaccid that's
not when it counts when it's hard that's
when it counts not the size of this ship
right it's the motion of the ocean no
not really
it's still dick size matters right girls
come on yeah am i right ladies
yeah
although it went from Game of Thrones -
hey girls
okay so they have some like snippets of
like certain scenes that were cut out
these are spoilers no they're not if
they're like I'm like no no no so we got
there's one from season seven but well
okay
yeah no world case that's order two
years old I think yeah also when we've
just given you guys like a 25 second
spoiler alert okay so one of the one of
these samples or examples of censorship
was in the first episode when Daenerys
is taking a bath when you first see her
with her brother yeah they they cut all
of that out so like you don't even get
the introduction to find out that Emilia
Clarke is fine yeah yeah yeah yeah that
baths in is actually very important for
plot point because the bath is extremely
hot and then her handmaid inside hi this
is really hot yeah it's way too it's too
hot and then she steps her foot in like
it's nothing so they already let you
know wait there's some temperature like
she's a mother a dragon in terms of
writing structure there's already
foreshadowing yep so I can see why their
shits all [ __ ] up cuz you're not
giving any of the foreshadowing oh
that's true
wait it's dragon born from Game of
Thrones or Skyrim both do they say that
did I bowl I never heard dragon okay
siren thing all right my back I was like
Dragonborn okay and then I mean close
enough I guess she I mean she like is
you know and then so then there's one
scene where viscera s-- is casually
fondling his sister's no it's not
vistors it's beyond no serious the
serious gets his head melted Daenerys is
in the beginning doing mission
jeez Oh Khal Drogo's gonna love these
things
and that's important too because like
that was a scene where they established
that he treats her as an object you know
like like doesn't like a commodity I was
gonna say that right now I'm actually
probably like the one person that's I
haven't seen a single episode of game
I'm gonna watch this for sure what what
is it why is it the best thing oh my god
I think they're just so so I think like
that storyline that's really good is I
got bunch of storylines yeah and art
direction and then they'll be writing in
a way where it's unpredictable okay
someone dies out nowhere but everything
is well motivated though everything is
unpredictable but still well motivated
and you're sitting in the throne chair
and the production is extremely high
like you watch this and you turn on any
other like medieval show and they all
look like [ __ ] now every season every
episode it's like a full-on movie huh
how many seasons to the heavy we're on
the eighth one right now a lot it's
pretty it's like an episode per season
no I read every season has different
amount of episodes yeah and they're like
an hour long like each like dude I'm
like I can't do it like I have stuff
it's probably like one of the best art
direction I have seen yeah ever right
like even things are subtle like let's
say this guy like you'll fight for maybe
three or four different houses as this
person is fighting you'll see even the
belt pattern it switches yeah but they
don't even mention it but it goes from
wolf - a dragon - like whatever and
they're just like oh [ __ ] like they
there's just so much things that are
inside that it's so like deep and
sophisticated awesome
is it like there's certain things that
different people can like appreciate hey
some people like the drama some people
like the sexiness of it mm-hm yeah
there's a lot of incest - you think they
cut out all the incest in China like
what if they cut out the whole incest
storyline like they have to not wait
I love it oh yeah yeah really
everybody's [ __ ] everybody like if
you're kind of hot you're getting bunker
shot
that's gaming [ __ ] me yeah just like a
win-win for everyone it's not yeah I
wonder if they I would everything how
kind of so you know who didn't [ __ ] that
I wish did you know the librarian boy
the fat guy with Samuel Samuel and his
girlfriend the other one did have a foxy
you know when he got his ass beat right
after he's in bed all like beaten up and
I blocked it out of my memory
wait so every character has a sexy
pretty much very much that girl got Down
syndrome or something huh who his wife
no she's just [ __ ] - she sounds pretty
smart
yeah she's just like a wildling but
tomorrow Monta Tommen tato talk about
that he would throws chair though that's
pretty dope oh yeah so nice to former
mayor and current councilmember Mitchell
in he made this for me which he'll make
that he's like yeah he put us onto the
show so are like and so he knows we love
Game of Thrones and then hey I made yeah
but like how does it go from hey check
this show out hey by the way is a
chaplain
I like how homeboys helping us like run
like the city government and in on his
part time he makes a game of Thrones
chair yeah Wow
like that's that's life it's some work
in it too you see they spent eight
weekends on it straight I want to see
politicians on the like highest level
dude like I want to see what what Joe
Biden does on it's like part time like
this he made Game of Thrones chair maybe
he makes crazy stuff we just never see
like the land office like what does it
Trump do does he do archery like he
doesn't have hobbies like what does he
do Joe's that I don't have any hobbies
the fact that he's like Ryan the
government he's like also I'll do a
little bit of painting today like you
know that's like real nice you don't
have a hobby concert yeah you play games
I don't do it as much anymore I'm in
this like weird transitional phase where
I need like new hobbies I don't like to
because if my apartment is small and I
feel like when I write cooked food is
sick I do like I got a lot of hobbies
you want one of mine is there really
random yeah like what like counting
pebbles are they I'm doing normal things
like right now I'm doing piano oh that's
what I'm specifically looking looking
for songs that were composed by homeless
people because it's not written yet so I
try to copy what they do right that's
like songs by homeless people compose
yeah - homeless composers all of that
combination dude out on the street with
a piano exactly in the world to create
some of my shoulder songs it was good it
was good yeah yeah look for homeless
people piano on YouTube so you'll see
some of the most dopest compositions you
can find that you specifically
I was looking for street performers uh
and then like these street performers
they were like classically trained
they're all perfect they're all good and
then I came across a homeless dude and I
was like what the [ __ ] this is totally
different and there's a hell of a lot of
emotion that's going on and it might not
be the most perfect but I was like this
is this is much more unique than you
know I feel something different from
this versus this yeah that's a technical
yeah I mean it sounds clean and
technical and they're like classically
trained and some of them might be really
well but like there was just something
completely different that was like he
looked like a [ __ ] member of a
character from Game of Thrones like he
had a bald head with long as hair like
like that dumb like you know you doing
that the piano match what he looked like
yeah he would play pee on like this
wasted your time on this here like he
made you watch like I've already seen it
we're gonna waste the time it was pretty
cool that's what I'm saying
I mean that's I think that's what we're
friends like I could get into your head
a little bit and understand why you
watch this shitty watch would you want
to take that hobby
[Music]